voting by mail has been part of u.s
elections for over a century
but the president insists this year it
will be catastrophic
claiming without evidence the process is
riddled with fraud
absentee is great but universal is going
to be a disaster
the likes of which our country has never
seen
it'll end up being a rigged election or
they will never come out with an outcome
they'll have to do it again and nobody
wants that and i don't want that
the bottom line is both terms refer to
delivering ballots by mail
and all ballots are verified
that hasn't stopped donald trump pushing
to cut emergency funding for the postal
service
enraging democrats and unions
the president of the united states
admittedly doing
everything he can including choking off
essential support for the united states
postal service
in order to prevent people from casting
their ballot
shame on him shame on him
and we will not let this postal service
run underfunded or god forbid defunded
we are in the middle of a global
pandemic
here in detroit workers have already had
their overtime cut
vital deliveries are being delayed and
yet so many
passionately believe the agency can
always be relied on
the postal service has a lot longer
tenure tenure
with the american people than donald
trump and the trust that they have
and they you know the postal service is
the only
only organization that every single day
touch every single american household
six days a week
do you think the president's attacks on
the postal service and
questioning it is going to undermine
people's faith they just don't believe
that they can
vote securely i think that's exactly
what they're trying to do i think by by
screwing with delivery standards by
purposefully delaying mail you undermine
public confidence our
you know right now we're polling at
about 91 favorable rating
that number starts to slip now you're
gonna have some individuals who won't
have confidence to mail their ballot in
and they may well be too afraid to go
out and vote in person
due to the fact we're still in the midst
of a pandemic there is undoubtedly a
huge logistical challenge ahead more
americans will vote by mail than
ever before a record 78 of people
will be eligible to receive ballots and
some states
will be sending them to everyone but the
u s postal service
has warned that millions may not arrive
in time to be counted
the postmaster general has just decided
to suspend the changes
blamed for slowing things down but there
is still
plenty of jeopardy and plenty of states
already working on a plan b